його доброї видачі з дав йому
російський православний собор прийме піт
ейфелевої поважаю 59 року в
дипломатичних супорт шок у жовті
2016 рак у собак із пружиною кішкам
росії з помпою особини став святим
московський патріарх до його Даниель струві
однак на вигляд шувай особливо часті знайти і
державну православну церкву на початку
двадцятого століття виродки нас чоловік вона
була і метрів від ссер до парижу водної
визначало поля дів більше ви kill the
linen а нині духовний стрибок та стрибок для
строго tea проза хіт на православному
громада
на задвірках пари стиснувши кулаки на
російських емігрантів їх по них від
італійського союзу
теж моїм за скронею з русів прибрати від
церкви
хмарного на іммігрантами ікони тут нам
про ливану противника ми стали на яке
сотнями та міхрова ладу франції і до
допомогла і зруби ти париш духовним
центром православних мирян прозахідних
пухля дю франсе я з радістю проймала
високо священних мігрантів з radiance
кого союзу і нині православні мати
дістати numis для молитви вище при пориві
близько 30 православних церковних
без собору силоміць можна було вбити тис
здається труби і бук про те собору за
спорудження устремління втілити
російських уряд сама там і на зливки для
нас за крима чини думаєте це логічний і
політичний тест на православний спиною
у Франції
омити і ванних про що у вас суперечка вже не
особливо уроки на відьому види російського
посольства розміщеної в самому центрі
парижа з хвали в чиє майбутнє при владі
екс президент ніколя саркозі та його на
ступні до франсуа олланд не важливий все
зуби немає і проект з політичних заходів
кубань
хоча пахан він ще чекаю попросили
russian і французи труби лади але
одному за словом "руски і за mavala"
гелікоптер у нас 7 країн у нас редакції а
борідкою
муза проти lovers in other на томі
французи моделі російського собору
статус дипломатичної чи буде чим за
галина її нормальним п'ятьма diplomatic
кожен тут луна і набити ледве видно давно
московський патріархат викликаючи протеїн за
ще до передачі його влада їсти будемо
прозахідних православних церкв у всій
франції мовляв x буду вали на російських
Однак таке затихання на розвелося
вона опер особливо його париже від церкви і
тут буду вали пари важливо за рахунок
приватних пожертвував ланцюга віджет числа
не документи
здається труби в плоскому позитивні
секції нам оиші пізніше став ще путін іди
тиш виточена ти був би на безтурботно
довжина 6 пілот і тпр початки механіки але
хоче пити те що ось це таке нове
росії
бузити ви значить і вся хто ван та ще й
брешу ти французьких православних
церквах моляться nlhe початки емігрантів
з Росії багатого реального російського
походження синовит священики віку розум
з духовними цінностями
мірою транслює політичними сочі
путіна про тайо і такі хто заради зрозуміли
собору то патронату Москви 12 рядів та
наші нам до води тихіше рази просто так про
простіше біля своїх фінансів у нас немає
і т.п. випуску штабного трюми ми прям
ще не для своїх культурно заходив для
Даниель строго ціни аргумент і його бочки
боровся за свободу віросповідання us
рср споришу т.п. і сам Даниель мусат
продовжу цю місію захищаючий вже
за ризиком православну спили ноту
піску збоку Москви